Hello, Kelsey, how are you?
Good, how are you?
Doing fine, thank you.
Hey, go see.
Hey, how are ya?
Hey, Michael.
Doing very well, Kelsey.
Hello.
Hello, Michael.
But.
Hey Michael, is Sean joining?
Let me check here.
Yeah.
Hey, Kelsey, he might go.
Hello.
Hello!
Partner.
That.
All right. I don't believe Sean is joining yet. I'm still waiting to hear back from him on Team, but I want to make sure here.
Yep.
Yeah, because I just wanted to introduce Manish to everyone. So if Sean can join, that would be great. Otherwise, that's fine. I mean, you can update Sean. No worries.
Yeah, he's on with one of our clients right now, but hopefully he'll be free soon.
Oh.
Okay, no worries. In the meantime, we can start. So first of all, thank you so much everyone for joining in. And I have Manish with me. So you will see more of Manish going forward. I'll be joining the call. But since we are making some internal changes, so Atlantic will be managed by Manish going forward.
OK, so we'll be working more closely with Banmeet, and together they'll make sure that if there are any concerns which I doubt, then Manish can help us. OK.
All right.
Hi, Manish, why don't you take a minute and introduce yourself?
Sure. Thank you, Kobe. Hi, Michael. Hi, Kelsey. My name is Manish. I'm working with IT by Design for 11 plus years now. Okay, and I started as a level 1 engineer, and now I have, I'm working in a capacity of a senior technical team lead, and I've been
in the people management role for last three years, 3 1/2 years now.
And that's the story for me so far. Started as a level 1 engineer growing up and now working as a senior technical team lead.
OK, thank you, Manish, and I believe you already know who Andy is. I don't have to tell this group about Andy. That's great. OK.
Yep.
Next up, I'm going to share my screen and...
Let me know, and you can see it.
I can see it.
Yep.
Awesome.
All right, so ladies and gentlemen, welcome to our monthly service review for LandTech. We'll be looking at April month's data. By getting into the agenda items, it stays pretty much the same. We'll go through the highlights, performance analysis, holiday schedule, build it 2026, team GPS, way forward, and then meeting minutes.
Getting into the highlights, Vineet and Michael, you worked on restoring the VM for Partner plane and fancy, so that was great. Vineet was very happy about that, so thank you. He also investigated the root cause for a GPU processing delay for Partner ASA, which was excellent.
Apart from this, he has been helping the team with the escalator tickets. So these are the highlights from last month. Before we get on to the next slide, Michael, Kelsey, anything that you want to add to this?
No, Vineet's been very helpful. He actually found a lot of tools, especially with that restore. It was on a very, very old version of VMware. And we had to force it into backwards compatibility mode, and he was a great resource for that.
****.
I.
The.
Yep, he's a one-man army. That's what we call him. He's a tank.
Yes.
It.
Okay, great. Kelsey, anything from your end?
No, Vineet's great, as always. We had an email hack for one of our clients a couple days ago.
No, Vineet's great as always. We had an email hack for one of our clients a few days ago. Vineet reached out. He was grumpy and didn't want our help, but Vineet was pretty much key in figuring out what was going on.
Mm.
Yeah.
Brilliant. Yeah, he is one of those individuals who just wants to do things by himself. So that's the best part. That's his strength and weakness as well, because he just wanted to make sure that he's working, finding the solution, and getting the job done. So happy to hear that. Thank you so much, Michael, Kelsey.
Moving on, as per his performance, looking at his...
Matrix starting from April, starting from Jan till April, his average billable utilization is 72%. There's a dip in April when I was going through his tickets and board. Last month he spent quite a bit of time working on like doing some research.
finding the resolution and that is why you see that kind of a dip. But otherwise, you know, as per his performance, I have no complaints. He worked on three projects, closed 56 tickets, top call drivers, projects, migrations, internal escalated tickets, server and phishing alerts. So that's his.
report card if you want to call it. Okay. Again, I'll go back to Michael, you and Kelsey for anything that you want to add.
I will say something that doesn't necessarily reflect in a lot of these that Vineet's been a big help with in the last month. We've actually had him investigate some of our current client setups as far as, you know, what kind of VMs they have and help us really pull together a full scope for.
No.
S.
I.
Just.
you know, upcoming migrations, whether it be moving people up to Intune and Azure and getting them off of on-prem servers. So it doesn't necessarily show as billable and tickets, but it's going to lead to a lot more in the coming months.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, exactly.
Absolutely. Yep. And that's exactly what I heard. And when I was going through his board, I also figured it out that majority of the time that he's spending is on the researching, trying to figure out things by himself, as Kelsey mentioned, that, you know, he's one of those individuals who just wants to find the resolution and make sure that solution is there. So.
Ohh.
Thank you.
Moving on, as for the holiday, the upcoming holiday is on Monday, next Monday. So I believe you don't need Vineet, right?
Yep.
Correct.
Right.
Okay.
A big thing, build it 2026. So is Sean coming this year?
I don't know, actually.
Yes, Sean is registered, I think.
Okay, okay, perfect. Then maybe he should get Michael, you or Kelsey. Because I'm not sure. Andy, do you see anyone else registered apart from Sean?
Yeah.
I see one more name, Brady. Is it right?
Yeah, Brady would probably also be there. He's the other owner of LandTech.
Okay, okay, right.
Okay, perfect. Yep, I'm sure they'll have an amazing time. So I feel for you and all of us because we will not be there. But you never know, maybe next year. All right, thank you. AI design, so this time around it will be part of our build it, so.
Lozy is.
Yeah.
Sean and Brandy, they will be able to, it's Brandy, right? Am I saying it correctly? Brady? Okay, Brady. Brady. Okay, cool. Yeah, so they both will be a part of our AI by design, and I'm sure they'll.
Ohh.
Ready.
Yeah, Brady, yeah.
Yeah.
Vaid.
Whatever they learn, they're going to share internally with all of you, so that'll be great. Team GPS, we all know about Team GPS. You have the...
QR code on the screen. If you need the demo, you can let us know. We'll be more than happy to schedule it.
Way forward remains the same. We need continues to be one of those individuals who wants to make sure that he is learning and growing every now and then to help business wherever he feel like he can add value to your environment, he's doing that. Apart from this, ITBD is committed to deliver the best product and we are ready to support any additional needs.
that may come up this year. That's the way forward. And with this, I'm going to stop sharing my screen.
What is it?
I'll go around the table for any questions, concerns, or feedback. So I'll start with Kelsey, you first, and then I'll go to Michael.
Leaders.
Chelsea.
No questions from me.
Anything from your end?
I know you're busy. You're working, right, Kelsey?
Yeah, sorry.
That's okay, that's fine. Thank you so much, by the way. I appreciate your feedback, Kelsey. And thank you so much for your support. We truly appreciate it. Michael?
Oh.
Of course.
I don't have anything at this time. Vineet's been very communicative. He's always on top of things, honestly, more so than some of our guys here. Yeah, we like having him as part of the team.
Oh.
Sing.
Touch.
Awesome. We are trying our best to see if we can give you more individuals like Vineet. We are trying to clone him. Maybe you never know with AI. You know, anything is possible, right? Okay, great. But thank you. Thank you, Michael, for your feedback as well. We truly appreciate it. To my team now, Andy.
Yeah.
Anything from your end?
Ahh.
I don't believe so at this time. We actually had a, yeah, we had some recent interns come in. I'm not, unfortunately, I'm not part of the hiring on that, but we have some interns currently and I'm not sure if that's going to lead to full time, but you know, we are, we certainly will reach out if it's necessary.
Okay.
The.
Phelps.
Thank you. Thank you, Michael. Just shoot us an email and we'll align interviews with you. Thank you.
Thank you.
That's it for me. Back to you, Gaurav.
Thank you, Andy Manish.
Thank you, Colin. Thank you, Kelsey and Michael, for the appreciation and your kind words for Vaid. I know him individually. Like personally, I've been knowing him for almost a year now. So he's a great chap to talk to and a great person, a great human being.
Yeah.
So I'm sure things are going to stay as it is and it will help us in strengthening our partnership with particularly me coming into the picture now. So it will be, I believe it will be kind of, I would say, an easier task for me to get
used to the environment that we have at Atlantic because of a sincere engineer like Vineet and appreciate appreciation from your side. So that's going to play a good role for me as well. Thank you.
Perfect. Thank you, Manish. Well, that's it from my end. Before we wrap it up, anyone any questions?
I don't have anything at this time. Thank you all for joining. It was nice meeting you, Manish.
Same here, Michael.
Mm.
All right, with this, I give you almost 16 minutes back. So Michael, Kelsey, and Joy, and we'll speak to you next month. Till then, have a good one. Take care. Bye-bye.
Hey.
Yeah.
Alright, thank you very much.
Thank you, you too.
Thank you. Bye-bye. Have a great day.
Thank you. Have a good day. Bye bye.
Bye-bye.